Okay, here's another example of how you can create
market structure shifts using the autofold training strategy.
So you can see that we were making hard, high,
hard, low, hard, high, high, low, hard, high,
and then we made this move, which broke this level.
Okay, there you go, it broke this level, this low.
Okay, high, high, low, high, high, high, high, high, high,
and then price broke this higher low.
So that is considered to be as market structure shift.
And then what you wanna do, remember,
you wanna draw your Fibonacci tool, not necessarily,
but if you just want to see where are the zones, right?
You wanna draw out the Fibonacci
from the top to the bottom,
and then you wanna choose the extreme zone, okay?
So as you can see, we got an autoblock
right around here.
What are autoblocks?
The first candle that create imbalance,
you can see first, second, third,
there's some gap here as well.
And basically, you do not, okay, so yeah,
so basically you can see you would have entered
right around here, put your stop loss
right above that level, and kaboom, very easy guys.
And you would have taken your take profit at this level,
which is another liquidity pool.
And before price went up, you can see price created
these relative equal highs, okay?
This is liquidity, this is basically a resistance level.
If that makes sense, okay?
So make sure you identify liquidity
before taking these entries.
If there's no liquidity, you're going to lose, okay?
If there's no liquidity, what's probably gonna do,
it's just gonna go up.
It will not respect your level
because there's no reason for it to respect it, okay?
So you can see price broke the structure,
there was a market structure shift,
then price engineered liquidity,
and then it went all the way up to the extreme zone
of that move that broke the market structure.
If that makes sense.
So this was another example, how you can use each
and everything together to trade.
So I'll give you now examples
for the long positions.